an update on the potential friends  reunion being developed by the upcoming  streaming platform HBO max exciting yeah  well we're now calling this episode the  one that may never happen it's not like  it sounds it's exactly like it sounds  HBO gave a less than promising update at  yesterday's TCA panel take a listen  there are reportedly two issues at hand  how much money the cast wants and the  direction in which the unscripted  reunion was going still feels kind of  relevant you know this show still really  popular with the streaming services and  always according to our source the cast  had been cautious about a reunion from  the very start and they quote don't want  to do the show and its fans a disservice  we always aren't trying to think of  something to do you know we just have to  figure out what the right thing is but  we will  [Music]